[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight for weeks that media
told you it was wrong to worry about the
corona virus a mysterious highly
communicable lethal disease spreading
rapidly around the world if that
concerns you in any way if you think
maybe we ought to take some steps to
protect ourselves from it then you're a
bigot coronavirus panic is racist
profiling against Asians lectured some
arrogant [ __ ] at Slate calm a writer
for the Seattle Times warned that quote
Yellow Peril racism was the real
epidemic fear and so on countless
publications wagged their fingers in the
face of readers and told them it was
irrational probably immoral in fact to
worry more about the corona virus than
the annual flu identity politics trumped
Public Health and not for the first time
woke Ness is a cult that lets you die
before they admitted that diversity is
not our strength so fast forward to
today what began as a regional outbreak
in the city of Wuhan China is now
spreading across Europe parts of Italy
are shut down tonight Catholic services
and in some places funerals have been
suspended indefinitely take a look at a
grocery store in Milan
that's Italy's industrial capital the
shelves are bare panic shoppers buying
in bulk as in a natural disaster which
this is and it's moving fast South Korea
has confirmed close to eight thousand
cases of the disease so far Japan is
reporting infections at the same level
the virus has even been reported in Iran
at least twelve people have died there
so far but one lawmaker says the real
death toll is at least 50 apparently
international sanctions don't stop the
coronavirus on Friday the Centers for
Disease Control warned that it is quote
possible even likely that America will
have a general coronavirus outbreak as
well that shouldn't surprise you China
is the world's most sophisticated
authoritarian government its leaders
have shut down entire cities dragged
people from their homes in an effort to
curb coronavirus but it hasn't worked
officials in our country have reported
about three dozen cases the virus in the
u.s. so far but that's a misleading
number the truth is we have no real idea
how many Americans are infected why
here's why
of yesterday only three public health
labs in the entire country were properly
equipped to detect the virus
fewer than 500 people in America have
even been tested for coronavirus out of
a population of 327 million for real
keep in mind that five and a half
million people ride through New York
City subway every day worried yet this
could be serious how likely is an
epidemic in the United States are we
ready for it if it comes how many could
die it's time for real answers to the
most basic questions about coronavirus